- (gagging) Makes me feel weird.
(lively music)
- My favorite Disney princess,
without a doubt, was Jasmine.
- Was Mulan.
- Was obsessed with Jasmine.
- I loved Ariel and I used
to swim around in circles
in my bathtub.
- No.
- Wow.
- Really, she looks like this.
- I guess I never really
thought about it before
cause Disney princesses are just like,
are, that's just what they
are, that's just how they look.
- So unrealistic.
- Like she got all her ribs removed.
- I think her waist is
the same size as her neck
in this photo.
- So basically, this would be my waist.
- But in the photoshopped
version, she looks gorgeous.
- If all the Disney
princesses had these waists,
then it wouldn't seem like any big deal.
It's just that you're
always comparing it to this.
I feel like I've been
conditioned to find B attractive.
- I get why you do it
cause it's a cartoon.
- Are today's toddlers,
when they watch this movie,
are they going to look
at this and one day,
look at their waists and be
like, why isn't it the size
of my neck?
- It's a slippery slope.
- Yeah, I think Disney princess
images affected me a lot.
- I think I wanted to
grow up to look like that
but I was always pretty
realistic and didn't think
it would actually happen.
- I know that it's pretty
ridiculous to blame Disney
for people's body image issues
but when you think about it,
it isn't that crazy.
- So normal to me that
it didn't feel weird.
That goes to show, like, how gross it is
that it's so subliminal.
- I thought to myself, like,
okay, maybe, I'm not as hot
as Jasmine is but one day I will be.
And like when that didn't happen, like,
I was kind of like, damn.
- I loved Jasmine's
little, tiny waist so much,
that I asked my mother
if I could remove a rib
so that my waist could look like that.
- I remember the day I was in
a nutrition class in college
and realized that women were
supposed to have stomachs,
like biologically fat, it's
supposed to collect there,
more than men.
And, I was so relieved.
- Like maybe Elsa has a
ballin', like, tiny waist
and then her sister's a little bit more
of like a ruler shape,
but hey, she's hot, too.
Can't you like mix it up a little bit?
- If we saw more princesses
that more accurately represent
who we are as a country,
then, like, I think that would
be a good place to start.
- If I could create a Disney princess,
what would I have her look like?
- She would be like ethnically ambiguous.
- A princess with an afro.
- Be super athletic and kick
a guy's ass and save the day.
- Or maybe one that has some
rolls when she bends over.
- Give her some hips.
- I would try to make like six.
I'd make like a troop.
And, they'd all have
different types of bods.
- Love to make a Disney
princess who's more central
to the action.
- No one's gonna save you except for you.
- You can be everything you wanna be,
no matter what size you are.